mec Caroline bonjour on peut dire que la
venue de Vladimir Poutine était bonjour
à sante pour le président sud-africain
absolument donc cette nouvelle
aujourd'hui qui émane de la présidence
10 ans que Vladimir Poutine ne sera pas
là
au mois d'août pour les briques s'ils
sont en fait représentés par Sergueï
Lavrov et effectivement rassurante pour
beaucoup de Sud-Africains qui
craignaient que cela n'embarrasse le
pays mais je crois que c'est surtout la
fin d'une très très longue saga ici ça
faisait des mois qu'on ne savait pas
exactement ce qui se passerait entre le
22 et le 24 août à Johannesburg parce
que le président Vladimir Poutine
voulait venir l'Afrique du Sud avait
tenté d'organiser ce sommet
virtuellement elle avait même pas les
autorités avaient pensé à le mettre dans
un autre pays et puis finalement il
fallait que le sommet se fasse
physiquement fin août et les autorités
de Pretoria ne se prononçaient pas sur
sur ce qu'il ferait ou pas Vladimir
Poutine et donc sous mandat d'arrêt de
la Cour pénale internationale depuis
mars aussi l'Afrique du Sud a signé le
traité de Rome donc était censé
l'arrêter mais il ne se prononçait pas
et tant est si bien que l'opposition le
premier parti d'opposition a finalement
entrepris une procédure judiciaire pour
forcer Pretoria à se positionner et on a
mieux compris les arguments de Cyril
Rama posa lors de ce procès la semaine
dernière puisque dans une déclaration
Cyril Rama posa a expliqué qu'il ne
pouvait pas arrêter Vladimir Poutine que
parce que ça pouvait être interprété
comme une déclaration de guerre et qu'il
n'avait aucun intérêt à être en guerre
avec la Russie et que
constitutionnellement il n'avait pas le
droit de déclarer la guerre à la Russie
par rapport au peuple sud-africain
d'autant qu'il y avait quand même des
menaces d'attaque nucléaire vis-à-vis
des ennemis de la Russie voilà ces
arguments il avait aussi ajouté que il y
a une entreprise de un processus de paix
fait par plusieurs pays africains et que
arrêter Vladimir Poutine et bien ça
serait saboter le processus de paix des
pays africains donc voilà les arguments
de Cyril Rama posa la procédure
judiciaire n'a plus lieu d'être puisque
maintenant on sait que Vladimir Poutine
ne viendra pas en Afrique du Sud le mois
prochain à Johannesburg merci Caroline
Caroline Dubé en direct de Johannes